so i want to pick up our conversation
about uh tulsi gabbard that we started
yesterday but really this is now
becoming a much bigger story and one of
the things i'm going to show you in a
bit is the ukrainian bio labs people
that now are fixated on the ukrainian
biolab story that's being promulgated by
you know tucker carlson glenn greenwald
tulsi gabbard the usual suspects these
are folks who have sort of their their
shiny new object instead of covet
anti-vaxx has shifted to become
ukrainian bio labs it's the same people
they're just now paying attention to
something else so
uh something really funny has happened
uh tulsi gabbard is now suggesting that
senator mitt romney resign and the idea
there is that anybody cares
what tulsi gabbard thinks about who
should resign that that's that's
hilarious and all of this is centered
around tulsi gabbard repeating
known long-time russian propaganda
talking points about ukrainian biolabs
so just as a reminder here's the clip
that started it all here are the
undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according to the us government these bio
labs are conducting research on
dangerous pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities
even in the best of circumstances could
easily be compromised and release these
deadly pathogens
now like covid
these pathogens know no borders if they
are inadvertently or purposely breached
or compromised they will quickly spread
all throughout europe the united states
and the rest of the world causing
untold suffering and death
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens that they
hold need to be destroyed
instead of trying to cover this up the
biden-harris administration needs to
work with russia ukraine nato the u.n to
immediately implement a ceasefire for
all military action the vicinity of
these labs until they're secured
and these pathogens are destroyed now
understand that with all of these things
they have kernels of truth like for
example
are there laboratories in ukraine yes
there are laboratories in ukraine that
research pathogens and bio-weapon
defense they're not developing
bio-weapons but they're researching
pathogens and bio-weapons defense they
there and and also in many other
european countries
and in other parts of the world so that
that's not untrue
um is it true that the us
through the dod
is part of a consortium
that is supporting the research being
done in a variety of these labs around
the world yes that's true but there's
nothing pernicious about it
would that would the existence of such a
lab in ukraine in any way justify
russia's invasion no of course not are
these the us's labs to order shut down
no they're not and so where this gets
into propaganda territory is that
some of the kernels that are there
aren't untrue in a literal sense but
it's being packaged as a way to provide
cover
for talking about things other
than the completely outrageous russian
russian invasion of ukraine and
specifically this is why this russian
talking point has been a talking point
about ukrainian bio labs for so long now
mitt romney wasn't having it republican
senator mitt romney tweeted tulsi
gabbard is parroting false russian
propaganda her treasonous lies while may
cost lives well we've also since learned
uh that uh tulsi didn't like this
and uh tulsi started demanding that mitt
romney resign and the idea that anybody
would care what tulsi gabbard thinks at
this point is genuinely hilarious tulsi
doubled down on twitter and she said
maybe romney needs to resign tweeting
quote mitt romney you have called me a
treasonous liar for stating the fact
that there are 25 u.s funded bio labs in
ukraine which if breached would release
and spread deadly pathogens to the u.s
and the world and therefore must be
secured in order to prevent new
pandemics now romney didn't say that
she's uh a traitor because she said that
that's what's going on
um and it's not clear that there are
more than 25 in ukraine that's actually
a question mark and they could spread if
they were breached but we don't know
that to be true but she went on to say
you claim that securing these labs is
treasonous
uh no he didn't say that securing the
lab's easter labs is treasonous
she said the spread of pathogens is what
will cause the loss of life not the
prevention of such spread and then says
senator romney please provide evidence
that what i said is untrue and
treasonous if you cannot you should do
the honorable thing apologize and resign
from the senate now of course uh mitt
romney was saying that her parroting of
russian propaganda is what's treasonous
now do i think it's literally treasonous
no it's almost certainly not and mitt
romney was using hyperbole but the idea
that tulsi is going to call for the
resignation of mitt romney is just
hilarious so the important things to
keep in mind about this story because
a week ago i would have said this is not
going to go anywhere
and now this story is everywhere and all
the usual suspects have seized on it the
substance of the story itself we went
over in detail yesterday in two segments
i don't want to do it all again since
you know how many times am i going to do
that in one week it's overall a really
great example of russell's teapot
russell's teapot is this idea that
bertrand russell came up with which
illustrates
the issue of burden of proof and in
particular burden of proof when people
make unfalsifiable claims rather than
shifting the burden of disproof to
others and the way bertrand russell
talked about it was in the context of
religion he wrote if someone says okay
um there's a teapot
orbiting the sun
or you know orbiting somewhere uh
orbiting the sun somewhere between earth
and mars
and it's too small to be seen
you wouldn't expect that anybody would
believe that
just because they can't disprove that
there's this tiny teapot you can if he
says there's there's this tiny teapot
and it's too small to be seen and too
small to be detected
it's very hard to disprove that but that
doesn't mean we just assume that it's
true that there is such a teapot and
this entire thing is based on proof the
u.s is perniciously funding bio labs
bioweapons labs and there's something
dangerous going on well we don't
actually have proof of that we we just
have all we know is there are labs all
over the world
and they research pathogens and they
research how to defend against the bio
weapons attack no no no but it's
the the pernicious nature of these is
being covered up well so then how would
we know one way or the other well it's
up to you to prove that it's not going
on how do you prove something's not
going on we just don't have evidence
that it is going on it's similar to the
invisible tiger example i've used before
which is hey
in my studio right here there's an
invisible tiger
really but the i can't see it no but
it's invisible okay well it's invisible
but it still has weight right so if we
put talcum powder down on the floor
we should be able to see the tiger
disturb the talcum powder as it walks
around no because it's a weightless
invisible tiger
oh okay all right well but i'm sure then
that if we
uh um uh open the door and put a little
bit of cellophane and then take the
oxygen out the tiger will try to leave
the room and we'll see it press up
against the cellophane right we'll see
this
no because it's an invisible weightless
tiger that has the ability to go through
the cellophane
it's it's endless it's a bottomless pit
and uh we need to understand that not
only are these claims uh essentially
unfalsifiable to the people making them
these are also uh much the same people
who were doing the anti-vaxx they've
just found a shiny new object here's ben
collins from nbc explaining this
let's talk about um
it reminds us of the theories that covet
19 was deliberately started in a lab
and spread out is does this start and
live in those kinds of places
yeah that account on gab was an
anti-vaxx account um you know that's
the remaining legacy of the anti-vac
spaces on the internet they are
conforming to be part of the broader
global far right to push these
conspiracy theories against the bidens
against anthony pouchy and against what
they would call like the medical
establishment all throughout the world
the global far right has coalesced
around that and it's worked for russia
too and in fact you know the tas the
russian news agency um they didn't post
anything about biological weapons
attacks uh that were created in ukraine
in the run-up in the one month before
the invasion in ukraine but on thursday
and friday they posted 24 separate
articles about what they called
biological weapons in ukraine this so
this is a long time uh long time story
uh being that that has come out of
russia in the past and now others are
helping to push it so that starts with
tulsi gabbard next we'll talk about
madison cawthorne
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below